alif they make hundred percent halal raw
cat food there are countless health
benefits to this new raw diet check them
out on instagram at alif dot uk they do
monthly subscription boxes and you can
get 10 discount on their two week trial
box with my code ali10 check them out
now
who is the one you worship and how do
you worship him
and how do you know him i just want
these things like i wanna know who is
the god you worship how do you know what
his attributes are and how do you
worship him okay well let's read his
attribute it was let's read the
israelites exodus chapter 15 and verse 3
the lord is a man of war
the lord is his name all right then
that's his attribute okay so is that
only a number it's just a god of war
is that it come
on laughing man
guys guys
guys i'm not here to make anybody
nothing no man come on man
everybody's free to believe nobody
should die
who should die look bro that's the whole
is
oh
one second he might find something funny
but we ain't going to stop so you all
could argue about no laughing hey come
on kind of kind of laugh he had the
right to okay
how can i refer to you guys
you have a name
firstly i don't agree with the whole
laughing thing reason why is because i'm
not here to make a mock of you guys i'm
here to learn from each other so even in
our religion that's my point that's the
point when we're talking to people i'm
not here to make points over you or make
you feel stupid because that's not my
point but i can't i can't control what
makes a man laugh no i know so let's not
go into
woman he's a masculine spirit he is
manly it's a man man he's a man of war
okay why would we say he's not saying
this this this part can become a joke
but that's laughing laughing brother you
trying to bring your point and i'm
standing on mine exactly everything is
war you create on russia is a war it's
the only the sun
stars is war sex is that halfway war
with your woman okay go ahead get it
yeah listen to you you gotta get in
there and get in there and after that
tour you're all tired and sweating on
the bed like you fall away okay so
is that his only action but he's the man
of war that's the main attribute that's
the main attribute that's the one okay
now one of the main attributes is that
god almighty is the most personal the
very merciful yeah
okay
how come that you had some of the people
who believe in yoga
doing unmerciful acts namely terroristic
acts to other people that's right
if
if your god is so merciful okay so i
think i think that's a good good
question but
it doesn't really make sense because
what you're trying to say in a nutshell
is that basically god almighty the most
merciful
but there's people who follow his
religion they go and do acts of
atrocities how do you connect and tie
that back to the most merciful because
they say they follow your god okay but
so how does that so for example the
person went and did the christchurch
attack
if he came and said i did it in the name
of i don't know a tree
do we go and blame the tree so for
example you guys live in a god of wrath
and war i will say to you why you guys
standing here or
like i don't know not masculine at all i
can say that i'm not disrespectful
i can say that because i said you fall
in a god of war who's masculine and his
main attribute was poor and i understand
you guys
some of you are the way you guys move
i've had interaction with the guys
before not used to the ones in oxford
street
and the thing is i can say why are you
guys not in professional warfare they're
not dinner to you
okay okay you just asked who we are
okay no no that's not you so i think
that question there god almighty in
islam is the most merciful but that
doesn't mean we're passive that means
what is that we're just gonna somebody's
gonna come but what they do there in the
name of islam is not islam because
nobody understands the tales they're
going through innocent people i'm
talking about how is it that the ones
who believe that that's
not right we're not going to war with
the ones we leave yeah
so are you here with me i've confronted
them
we're talking about god's attributes
which is more severe because we believe
the biggest citizens associate partners
to god so i'm
i'm saying how do you guys do you
believe god can come into his creation
do you believe he's a man because he
said he's a man but in what sense so do
you believe he has those attributes to
come to earth do you have a family yes i
have a family
how are you with your family
my dad
doesn't like yourself that's your family
you are part of your dad's family
okay your family your family your wife
or wives and your children that's what
you mean by family because it's a family
we believe in islam iman is sicker than
blood so we believe as believers he's my
family
you get it so so it depends what you
mean by time if you mean that
biologically that's different if you
mean faith-wise these are all my family
here okay yeah well well the lord deals
with one race of people
which is the children of israel okay
that's what he that's what that's what
he is okay that's his family
okay he is
he is our father he's the most high
power of all the years okay okay but he
chose the children of israel to be his
own right okay right so but again it
doesn't answer my question what is the
attribute
that's my ass if you have a family okay
lord is a father and if you are a father
with children and stuff you could
understand you could understand your age
with your children
you could understand the rage when
somebody else children try to violate
yours okay you could understand your age
when somebody pretends to be you and
taking benefits that you should get
in your name even though they're not you
that's the law true okay team upk let me
tell you the concept as muslims for us
here we believe
so i just want to make this clear so you
know from our point of view and let me
know if you agree or disagree with me
yeah okay i'll tell you i'm not okay i
disagree
you just said you're muslim okay so from
the get-go yes okay no problem but then
again this doesn't you have to counter
my uh one [ __ ] i don't have to
counter it okay you want me to but
that's what you're saying
the moment you say you're black i'm like
i don't want to know you for some reason
exactly
i didn't say i didn't say
i didn't say
i don't want to know you okay i said i
don't agree with you okay but you take
that to me i don't want to know you
because really let me ask you this
what's your end game
for you guys it's islam
for you i'm telling you right now
to help with islam right right right now
i'm telling you right now you're not
ready let
your people have never done anything for
mine right now
your people actually participated in the
slave trade that destroyed my people
yeah what's your nationality
is
so number one number two in islam which
is very unique are you not finding any
other religion is that we single out
allah and his worship what that means is
we do not go through jesus we do not go
through ganesha we do not go through
muhammad peace be upon him
because
whatever it is
black people who they really are instead
of pimping them
and i'm going to show you why we will
never follow him
something i haven't seen any of these
messages
and who do they worship who do they
worship it's irrelevant at the bible
of the bible they follow them you see
that but not against us
they use that against them you use
do you worship god directly or do you go
for jesus
jesus black rick referees of one more
time
can you answer my question
one more time say it say it again repeat
i trust me
okay i'm asking a question do you
believe god is a man that is black yes
okay let me get this right and this is
silk you know what they believe they
believe god almighty who created the
heavens and the earth the
the powerful uh one of his attributes is
wrath came to earth like me flesh black
black
okay you believe it's a black man did
you ever come step on earth in this
creation no he never no okay so when you
say he's a black man can you give me a
bit more description about because to me
point out to me here black man
[Music]
he look like you right i'm jesus and you
believe that
come on man no no listen
listen your argument your arguments fell
apart
minute minute i said he didn't come to
earth you know what
you muslims try
to box black people in not black oh come
on i'm black man
i'm black
why are you trying to convince me
because
because i'm muslim bro okay you're
[Applause]
it doesn't matter
if you tell me god is a man and he's
black he is not worthy of worship so a
black man is not worthy of worship
that's racism
that's racist what do you mean what's
your favorite sport
and who is the champ doesn't matter what
means
this is yours
i admire god that's the only way i
admire him and him alone
this is lost
i'm calling you to the worship of god in
god i'm not going to follow you into
worshiping our world
i'm not going to follow you into worship
in a rock right okay are you done
i'm never going to do it so that means
for example when jews i don't know which
way you guys direct direction to pray so
does that mean you're worshiping let's
say jerusalem
does that mean that's your blood now
do you face a direction when praying
okay so let's see
what if i can't face
you what if i count
muslims
had borne unto abraham mocking
wherefore she said unto abraham cast out
this one woman he said get out of the
house
and her son
one seed alone
[Music]
this isn't god's record
who said god
go ahead please